christian lindner entscheidet die wahl
echt ja in fast allen möglichen
koalitionsoptionen ist die fdp mit dabei
als voraussichtlich kleinste kraft biker
mit union und grünen bei der ampel mit
spd und grünen
also ist die fdp der königsmacher
bestimmt sie wer kanzler wirken
[Applaus]
wer die fdp verstehen will muss
christian lindner verstehen schaut euch
mal die werbespots an christian lindner
ist die fdp so sieht es jedenfalls aus
und das alles beschäftigt dich bis tief
in die nacht aber obwohl es nicht die
ganze zeit beschäftigt hat es ist nicht
erledigt und du weißt du musst etwas tun
ich musste immer an ein altes entdecken
being john malkovich wurde zuschauer in
den kopf von john malkovich hinein
steigt und jetzt biegen christian
lindner wir müssen wissen dass christian
lindner und die fdp vorhaben ist nicht
leicht macht mancher vielleicht auch
nicht so gern kommen wir aber nicht
drumherum
[Musik]
christian lindner ist ein politiker der
uns hauptstadtkorrespondenten immer den
eindruck vermittelt dass würde er uns
quasi exklusiv
zugang zu seinem strategie zentrum geben
und geheime einblicke geben und die
hauptstadt ausblenden wir lieben
exklusivität da machen wir alle mit ich
auch ich erinnere mich an ein gespräch
mit ihm im frühjahr diesen jahres in der
leeren lobby der fdp zentrale in berlin
mitte es ging um das worum es auch jetzt
geht wer könnte mit wem koalieren und
was will lindner was wir die fdp lindner
sagte mir damals das was auch heute sagt
am liebsten hätte jamaika mit armin
laschet und ich konnte mir die sachen
nicht verkneifen dass ich zu ihm sagt
ina ja hätten sie mal 2017 zugegriffen
da in jamaika verhandlungen damals
da sind sie weg gelaufen es ist besser
nicht zu regieren als falsch zu regieren
lindner war mein einwand gar nicht
lustig und ich war erstaunt darüber mit
welcher werft er noch heute vier jahre
später über angela merkel schimpfen
konnte kennen sie den unterschied nicht
zwischen kohl und merkel fragt er mich
nie wusste ich natürlich nicht er beim
metal würden verhandlungen die darin
bestehen dass sie bis ins letzte detail
verhandeln würde und am ende
steht die fdp immer mit leeren händen da
bei kohle als anders
schwarz-gelben zeiten habe es
kabinettssitzung geben mit sagen wir
drei offenen punkten kurse reingekommen
aber gesagt und den drei kriegen zwei
wir ein kriegt die fdp ich habe mich
viel zeit regel tier das linden hat das
voller bewunderung erzählte rheinische
kompromiss demokratie und noch viel
besser fahren der da spanien laschet das
in düsseldorf in der landesregierung mit
der fdp ganz genau so praktiziert
rheinische kompromiss demokratie und
deswegen hat christian lindner über
monate hinweg nichts anderes gemacht als
den eindruck zu vermitteln als sei diese
bundestagswahl lässt sich schon gelaufen
ist ge alles unausweichlich hinzu
jamaika unter einem kanzler armin
laschet und so hatte er es gerne ein
finanzminister
lindner deshalb erwarte ich eine
regierungsbildung unter führung der
union wegen der des momentums eigene
sache habe ich bei diesem gespräch in
der leeren lobby der fdp-parteizentrale
gelernt christian lindner ist eitel sind
die meisten berliner politikern aber bei
ihm geht es soweit das ist gelegentlich
ein bisschen er plötzlich wirkt wenn die
fdp und das heißt christian lindner
nicht genug platz zum strahlen haben
dann läuft er davon sowie 2017 und alle
sind davon überrascht weil es so abrupt
geschieht bei einer koalition mit armin
laschet als lindner dass er in die
situation nicht kommen wird olaf scholz
ist dass sich da nicht so sicher
das ist das problem
[Musik]
es gibt alte geschichten und trauma die
werden jetzt wieder wichtig für
christian lindner die fdp ist es das
jahr 2013 damals regierten die liberalen
zusammen mit der union und angela merkel
dann kam die bundestagswahl und die fdp
flog nicht nur aus der regierung sondern
sogar aus dem bundestag hat es bis dahin
noch nie gegeben ein absoluter schock
für die fdp eine nahtoderfahrung für die
partei aus den staats karossen für
minister und staatssekretäre hinaus
in die politische wüste christian
lindner hat darüber ein buch geschrieben
schatten jahre heißt es darin sind heute
zwei dinge wichtig erstens für lindner
ist vor allem mitschuldig am scheitern
der fdp angela merkel den liberalen
nichts mehr gegönnt hat und zweitens
lindner hat nicht vergessen wie 2013 am
wahlabend spd und grüne gejubelt haben
über das ausscheiden der fdp nicht mehr
aus der regierung sondern eben auch aus
dem bundestag
[Applaus]
das hat er ihn nicht vergessen das
misstrauen dass es geblieben
[Musik]
christian lindners traum ist mit armin
laschet zu regieren den kennt ja da gibt
es inhaltlich die größten
überschneidungen aber zu zweit wird es
nicht reichen sie brauchen die grünen
irgendwie müssen sie die ja überzeugen
christian lindner glaubt sie kriegen das
selbst dann hin wenn die spd als
stärkste kraft aus dieser wahl
hervorgeht aus mehrheiten ergeben sich
nichts mehr im jahr
2021 die inhalte aus den inhalten
ergeben sich in diesem jahr die mehrheit
ich glaube das ist wunschdenken wenn die
union nur halbwegs das ergebnis erzielt
das die umfragen im moment vorhersagen
also verluste einfährt von 10 plus sechs
prozent
dann ist das ein desaster und dann fragt
sich jeder woher will diese union ein
regierungsauftrag ein mandat des volkes
für sich ableiten jamaika ist dann
ziemlich passe und
die strategie von christian lindner auch
selbst unions leute sehen das nicht
alexander dobrindt zum beispiel hat
kürzlich dem spiegel gesagt der
regierungsauftrag geht an die stärkste
fraktion im bundestag so eine regierung
unter führung einer zweiplatzierten
union sieht mir gerade die fantasie
nicht christian lindner der bleibt im
moment noch bei seinen wunschdenken
vielleicht weil er sich noch nicht
eingestehen will dass er langsam aber
sicher in eine richtung geschoben wird
in die er nie wollte
[Musik]
für eine ampel hat christian lindner
immer die gleiche höhe der gesetzt ihr
fehlt die fantasie wie überhaupt rot und
grün der fdp ein angebot machen könnten
die stehen in der sache der linkspartei
ja viel näher als uns und auf dem
parteitag am sonntag vor der wahl hat er
noch einmal kräftige rote linien gezogen
wir schließen aus steuererhöhungen wir
schließen aus aufweitungen der
schuldenbremse das hört sich nach
knallharten forderungen unserer rück
barren standpunkten an es wagen killer
kriterien für eine mögliche koalition
sind sie das echt nehmen wir die
schuldenbremse die grünen würden sie
gerne auf weichen für investitionen in
die zukunft in die infrastruktur in
bildung in digitalisierung die fdp ist
gegen ein aufweichen der schuldenbremse
das ist ihre knallharte forderung wir
schließen aus aufweitungen der
schuldenbremse gut die schuldenbremse
steht im grundgesetz artikel 109 wer
also die schuldenbremse aufweichen will
oder ändern will muss das grundgesetz
ändern und braucht dafür eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag
die ist weit und breit nicht in sicht
linden erkämpfte also für etwas vehement
was er eigentlich schon hat andererseits
dass in diesem land ist einen großen
investitionsstau gibt bei bildung bei
digitalisierung bei der infrastrukturen
da sind sich alle einig insbesondere spd
grüne und die fdp die frage ist also nur
wie muss sie finanziert werden und
selbst die forderungen der fdp
ihre wahlversprechen
lassen eine finanzierungslücke offen das
haben wirtschaftsinstitute berechnet von
bis zu 90 milliarden euro also nach der
wahl wird auch die fdp erklären müssen
woher das geld kommt keine
steuererhöhung das war die zweite
knallharte forderung der fdp
da habe ich gespannt wie weit sie das
durchhält wie gesagt sie selbst hat in
ihrem wahlprogramm einen 90 milliarden
euro loch ich glaube diese knallharte
forderungen der fdp
diese hohe latte die sie angeblich dafür
eine ampel legt die ist in wahrheit gar
nicht so hoch irgendwo wird sich da
schon einen kompromiss finden zwischen
subventionen kürzen und vielleicht doch
steuern für ganz reichen zu erhöhen
bemerkenswert ist außerdem dass lindner
bei seinen knallharten forderungen über
zwei punkte gerade nicht redet rote
linien zieht der nicht bei der
klimapolitik und nicht bei der
sozialpolitik wo fdp auf der einen seite
spd und grüne auf der anderen
in ein paar punkten doch ziemlich weit
auseinander liegen aber
offenbar ist das kein
ausschlusskriterium für ihn für eine
ampel
[Musik]
also was passiert jetzt die wahl ist
offen ist knapp und christian lindner
rückt plötzlich von der union ab wirbt
um union stimmen war lange unklar und
ist es im grunde bis heute für was steht
die union in der steuerpolitik im
programm ist etwas geschrieben worden
von entlastungen das hat herr laschet
relativiert man weiß es nicht mehr genau
und versteht sich plötzlich erstaunlich
gut mit der robert habeck von den grünen
was bedeutet das für bienen christian
lindner was geht den lindners kopf vor
er muss um seine jamaika strategie
fürchten kann sein dass die am ende
nicht aufgeht und dann dann bleibt ihm
eigentlich nur die anti karl marx hat
gesagt geschichte wiederholt sich immer
zweimal das erste mal als tragödie
das zweite mal als farce allerdings ein
tragischer held kann man in der politik
durchaus sein und wie christian lindner
nach 2017 dann wieder auferstehen
aber eine farce das überlebt man
politisch viel schwerer was denkt ihr
was geht in christian lindners kopf und
welche ausfahrt werden er und die fdp am
ende wählen schreibt mir und abonniert
diesen kanal und für alle weiteren
videos schaut nach auf der playlist von
inside politics da gibt es noch viele
gute und spannende sachen und ein
letztes geht wählen